listen the the answer to your question  like how do you begin how do where do I  even start you start by starting  you have to get out of your head and  outside of like all the baggage that's  holding you back it feels like you want  to know where it's going to lead you or  you want to have all of your questions  resolved and answered before you begin  and that's just not how it works the way  it works is Universe conspires to  support you when you put in the work and  you show up for it clearly you have  something inside of you that's nagging  you to be brought to life and every day  that goes by where you ignore it is not  in service to who you are it is not in  service to your authentic self get into  action begin make it a practice and make  that practice non-negotiable create  structure around that practice and then  protect that structure above everything  else